that's her I just took a Shh the
backyard freedom run hello and welcome
to Friday re where we take a look back
at my week it makes sense sometimes and
also completely all the time doesn't
really make any sense
it's basically my version of a
traditional cable sitcom clip show
this happened remember when that
happened I look amazing
you look am it okay do you run my walk
I'm too sexy for my love too sexy for my
oh man that's right that other thing
happened hello we are headed over to
memories place that's Sunday the Lord's
Day and we are gonna start a marathon
day of shooting with her and Hannah
we're shooting much wine at first and
then
during the day we will be hopefully
making it follow-up to the epic video
that went up on Hanna's channel a couple
years ago my drunk pumpkin you haven't
indulged yourself go over and watch it
we're making the sequel tonight suppose
that they mostly have a cup and also
we're going to shoot something for my
channel as well I'm really excited I say
that we're getting this day started
early it is 12:50 p.m. the Lord rested
on the last day I'm working we've made
it to memories house we're marathon
shooting some wite-out right now oh my
god she just made this thing for Mila
Kunis that you guys will see in the
future it's basically a banana shake
with a whole bunch of booze in and it's
in and in in it and in it memories get
any more into blogging now you're doing
a great job much that's how many bugs
for crossing streams oh that was a great
stretch we're at Hannah's house
currently we are getting set up for the
sequel of my drunk pumpkin who's done
yeah the composition of this shot right
now it may be like a little head on my
shoulder you did the first step of my
drunk pumpkin is we got drunk oh yeah
none other thing happened hello good
morning
it is Oh Tuesday yeah good to know we
are headed to the meet up with makeup by
Mandy
she is a makeup guru here on YouTube and
she's adorable
and she's a teenager and I am NOT and
I'm wearing this necklace to
overcompensate and hope that she doesn't
know that I'm not a teenager
Frank are so hard things start turd
things turned frustrating really fast I
went to the wrong address
I'm currently 35 minutes late to this
shoot
making great first impressions I'm
terribly sorry Mandy you're still so
young this is an old people thing is
being late okay we didn't we shot the
video Sundance was grapes she's adorable
so fashion forward headed home to the
gauche you were getting dangerously
close to getting 86 for stealing focus
which I mentioned this that happened
okay
baguette home wait oh my assistant is on
the clock she also doesn't want to show
her face on camera she's in the witness
protection program currently I am
working on I have all of these Grace's
guide dogs and so unprofessional
and I'm sending them to a bunch of
people that I really want to have them
but I'm trying to make them a little
special so I ordered to any travel
deodorants that are going in each
package I ordered about 100 of these so
I'm set for you know travel for the next
like week
[Music]
she's on our lunch break then that
happened we're currently in backstage at
@midnight I'm in the green room right
now
look at how classy Oh Hollywood just an
empty murder corner that's fun and then
in cuffs necks just like those
high-class everywhere Stu huge here the
restroom facilities clinical it is back
then this happened how are you holding
the camera
weird hi guys we are in the car because
we are headed to I'm not going the way
this girl wants me to go so she keeps
letting me go left such a liberal car
we're headed to the soup you following
the road 4600 feet oh I turned the
camera on and then you change your
opinion about we had to do something on
the soup
hosted by Joel McHale so I'm really
excited to meet I've never met him it's
you Martin Luther whoo this is for the
internet literally anyone well I wasn't
eventful week that was huh crazy stuff
happening also today Friday unless I am
publishing this on Saturday but I think
Friday the trailer for the full length
episodes of hey ése
on the scene calm when up the link is
around somewhere it the trailer looks so
good the episodes look so good I you
guys are really gonna love this I know
you've only seen bits and pieces all
summer long but the full-length episodes
are just so fun and there's so many so
many things you guys haven't seen yet
and so many moments of memory and I
really tried to forget after the fact
that you guys will get to sleep have fun
and also you get to see the slow rolling
transformation of my hair from brown
blunt really life-changing stuff hope
Annika week I don't know
with consent